everyone back to the thursday edition of
the
workshop on
learning in the presence of strategic
agents it's my pleasure i'm grant
chainabek it's my pleasure to introduce
our first speaker annie liang who's an
assistant professor in economics at
northwestern university as well as the
carr family assistant professor in
computer science
annie's done
really interesting and fascinating work
on models and asking what makes a good
model and
really uh digging down deep and
providing interesting answers to these
questions and i hope she'll tell us more
about that uh here now so take it away
annie
awesome thanks a lot grant um i
apologize for not being there in person
i very much would have liked to be there
but uh undergraduate teaching started
this week so it just wasn't possible
um but i'm delighted to be presenting
this paper uh this is joined to work
with isaiah andrews uh who's an
econometrician at harvard uh drew
feudenberg who uh presented earlier in
this workshop childhood who's a
northwestern uh computer science student
and uh the paper so by the way this is a
new paper it's our first time presenting
this so your feedback is going to be
very welcome
so the paper is about uh the transfer
performance of economic models so what
do i mean by that
okay well suppose you train a model on
data okay
you might hope that the model that you
get is going to be useful not only in
the specific domain from which your data
was drawn
but more broadly for predicting
behaviors and other related domains as
well
all right so for a concrete example
suppose you have access to a data set
consisting of evaluations of risky
lotteries made by subjects in the united
states let's call that our us data
you can use that to estimate a model of
risk preferences you might be interested
in how risk-averse these subjects are
now that model is certainly going to be
useful for predicting future evaluations
of risky lotteries again made by u.s
subjects but you might hope that the
model is uh useful beyond that so for
example uh if you were to predict
evaluations made by german subjects you
might hope that this model would still
be informative about that okay maybe not
quite as predictive as for uh us
subjects but still predictive
all right now how well a model transfers
is going to depend on whether the model
has captured generalizable structure
that holds across these different
domains
and this uh this property of whether a
model is in fact transferable has become
i think more interesting as of late uh
now that people are increasingly using
black box algorithms in place of these
economic models right so we can estimate
an economic model of risk preferences or
we can train a black box
if you take that black box you can use
that equally to make predictions um
on the new data sets
and it's always a little bit fuzzy you
know what we mean by black box versus
economic model but let me just highlight
one uh one key difference which is
whether the architecture is designed
specifically for the setting you have in
mind
all right so this is a depiction of a
random forest
we can use random forests to predict uh
evaluations of risky lotteries we can
use essentially the same algorithm to
classify whether an image has a cat in
it
in contrast economic models tend to be
very tailored to the specific problem
you're interested in so this is a
depiction of what's called a
cumulative prospect theory it's actually
a model we'll talk a lot about today
and the idea here is that individuals
have a value function over money which
treats gains and losses differently
moreover people misperceive
probabilities and there's a very
specific parametric form for how these
misperceptions
uh are uh enacted
okay so this is a model that we can use
to predict
evaluations of rescue lotteries we
probably can't use this to classify
images
all right so um
you know despite the increased
popularity of black box algorithms even
for economic prediction problems uh
there's still uh
quite a lot of reliance on these
traditional economic models and we think
one of those reasons is because people
have an intuition
that economic models do a better job of
capturing general structure than black
boxes do and thus these economic models
are going to transfer better across
domains
right it's a very reasonable intuition
we don't know if that is in fact so
all right so in this paper what we do is
the following
we first provide a framework for the
transfer prediction problem it's going
to be a very straightforward extension
of the usual statistical learning
framework where instead of out of sample
testing we're going to be looking at out
of domain testing
right then within this framework we're
going to provide finite sample forecast
intervals
for the predictive performance of a
model on unseen data from a new domain
okay so crucially we're allowing for the
distributions to differ across these
different domains
and these intervals are going to be
useful for evaluating economic models
and block boxes alike
all right then we're going to
demonstrate the methodology by applying
it to a specific setting which is uh
predictions of certainty equivalence for
for lotteries
and here what we find is that
if we look at the classic out of sample
test right so we look at um
within domain prediction problem where
the training data and the test of test
data are drawn from the same domain
then we find that the black boxes that
we use
outperform the economic model that we
that we consider
now there's two possible reasons this is
the case so one possibility is that the
black boxes are learning generalizable
structure that the economic model misses
right the economic model imposes a
certain structure if there's structure
that the model is missing
you know potentially the block boxes are
learning something that's a that's a
general irregularity across domains uh
that we would like to know another
possibility is that the black boxes are
learning idiosyncratic details of the
different domains which do not in fact
generalize across settings okay so for
example 13 is an unlucky number uh in
the united states
it could be that when that number
appears in a lottery uh subjects
consider that lottery to be less
valuable if that same number is not
unlucky in uh in germany then it could
be that that you know the black boxes
potentially going to learn this
idiosyncratic detail uh which will in
fact result in better predictions for
the u.s population um but this this
detail may not be one that in fact
allows the black box to predict well in
the german data
okay so we can separate these
explanations by looking at the transfer
performance of these models which is
what we do and we find that in fact
although the economic models have worse
performance out of sample within domain
they do in fact transfer more reliably
across domains
this suggests that the representation
that the economic model is learning is
indeed more general
all right um so a couple of comments on
the relationship to the literature so
there is a literature called domain
generalization within computer science
so in a sense we're contributing to this
uh there's a difference in focus where
this literature is uh
more interested in developing new
algorithms with good out of domain
generalization
uh we're going to ask instead if you fix
a given model or procedure
can we provide a confidence interval for
the out-of-domain generalization error
of that model and procedure
within economics there's a literature on
meta-analyses so these papers typically
focus on how much an estimated parameter
varies across settings so you might look
at say this risk aversion parameter
we're going to focus instead on the
accuracy of the model's predictions so
these are related but uh
but different
so for example you could have very
stable parameters across settings uh but
still the model's transfer performance
could be very poor
okay finally there's been a recent
literature looking at uh
how black box methods and economic
models differ from one another
for example there's been recent papers
that uh that demonstrate that black box
methods actually outperform economic
models in out-of-sample tests across
various uh various problems
um so our results complement this by
suggesting that these black box methods
may nevertheless be worse at transfer
prediction so you know these are both
important angles on on this comparison
uh and this is just a another comment on
it
okay so are there any questions about
the the goals of what we're doing
okay
so if not let's go into the framework
okay so as usual there's going to be a
feature space x and an outcome space y
okay as usual a sample is going to mean
a set of observations
x y drawn from some distribution on this
space
now
departing uh from the usual statistical
learning framework we're going to
suppose that the analyst has access to
metadata
consisting of n samples
okay so for example these might be an
american data set a bulgarian data set
new zealand data set
okay each sample again consists of these
observations
and we're going to suppose that the
samples sorry the metadata is generated
in the following way
okay so we're going to assume existence
of a distribution mu
in the following space
where this first part is
the set of distributions on this
cartesian product
okay so the set of possible joint
distributions for x y
the second part is uh the possible
sample
sizes and what we're going to suppose is
that each sample
si
is generated by first drawing a pair pm
from this distribution mu
all right then once we've drawn this pm
we're going to independently draw m
observations x y from this joint
distribution p
all right we're going to abuse notation
by writing this more simply as s i uh
being drawn according to mu
understanding that that means really
this this procedure here
so then going back to our example right
to generate this this metadata
for each of these domains what we do or
how we how we uh model or understand
this uh the situation is
we're assuming that there is a pair pm
drawn for each of these domains
right so again remember this this first
one is this uh distribution on x times y
the second is a sample size
okay we're drawing this importantly
independently across each of these
domains
uh then we're drawing that number of
observations from that joint
distribution collecting those
observations that
gives us our sample for each of these
domains
all right now this assumption that
distributions are iid across the
different samples
is certainly restricted uh but it's
going to be important for making
progress on this problem so we see it as
a useful first step
all right now the transfer prediction
problem uh is is as follows so we have
our initial metadata so all of this is
observed and we're going to suppose that
there's a new sample sn plus 1 which is
again independently drawn from the same
distribution mu
okay this we don't get to observe
all right then
taking the the usual decision problem uh
what we suppose is that the analyst is
going to choose a strategy to use in
this new target domain so a strategy is
a mapping from the set of observed
features into actions
for example the action might be a
prediction of the outcome y right so you
get to see x um you're going to use that
to predict y
okay then the accuracy of that
prediction
is measured using a loss function
which takes as input the action uh and
the true outcome outputs a number okay
so i'm saying prediction it doesn't have
to be a prediction right and what's
important is just just that the payoff
consequences of the action that you take
depends on the realization of why
okay and then as usual we're going to
say that the error of the strategy sigma
on a given sample s
okay which we're writing as e of sigma s
that's going to be the average loss of
the strategy
on observations from the sample s
right so for each x y in the sample
we're using sigma to decide what action
to take
then we're using the loss function to
decide uh to evaluate the uh the sort of
the error or the
the consequences of taking that action
when the true outcome is why
all right so eventually we're going to
be interested in uh evaluating the error
of a strategy that we pick on this
unseen target sample um so then the
crucial question is how do we choose
this strategy and there's really two
choices here
um so the first choice is what part of
the metadata to use for training
okay
now you might think that we just want to
use all of the metadata uh as we'll see
if we're interested in bounding your
error on the target sample sometimes
it's going to make sense not to use all
of the metadata but instead to use some
part of it for training
okay and second and this is really the
main content
you need to choose how to map the
training data
into a strategy for use on this target
sample
and there's many different things you
could do right you could train a black
box you can estimate an economic
an economic
model
all right so now in more detail um so
the first part is choosing what part of
the metadata to use
so we're going to let t here be a subset
of the uh
of one through n
and this t is going to index
the samples that we're going to use for
trining
so mt here
is going to be our training data
and that's defined as the union of all
samples indexed by one of these training
domains
so for example we might say okay let's
use the american data the bulgarian data
for training in this case t would be
the set one two
and our training data would be the union
of all observations in s1 and s2
all right then we're going to choose a
decision rule row
which is any mapping from samples s
into a potentially randomized strategy
sigma
all right so given this training data
what is the strategy that you want to
learn
okay for example uh you might use that
training data to estimate the free
parameters of an economic model
or you might use that training data to
train a black box algorithm
what you get is going to be a strategy
that you can then ultimately use for
making uh decisions
on this target sample
all right and then this uh the slide
gives the crucial definition of transfer
error which we're going to be interested
in bounding
so fixing a sample d
we're going to use this simpler notation
e subscript td
to mean the transfer error
when we use the strategy row of mt so
this is applying the decision rule row
to the training data mt
okay so again remember that's the
strategy so we use that strategy on the
sample sd
okay and then we evaluate
the average loss on that sample
okay that's going to be our transfer
error
okay so any questions about the model or
our definitions
yes
the transfer error comes from just using
the data you have trained on independent
you know independent from the transfer
set
um
and just bond the error on the transfer
set doesn't mean you don't really
consider things like um
potentially depending on the data
generating process
several data sets may have kind of
neutralized some useful effects
so that's one and the other so learning
a mix strategy like mixed data set might
not be the best model
and the second thing is that so in
domain generalization and machine
learning in general there's a notion of
domain adaptation where you somehow
receive a few samples from the target
and then you kind of adapt your model
and fine-tune it for that domain this is
not does it set up kind of excluder
yeah great um
let me start from the second question uh
so so right uh in this talk i'm going to
focus on just transfer error um but in
the paper we actually define another
measure called transfer deterioration
uh where the question that we ask is
what is the value of obtaining new data
from the target domain so that's very
similar to what you were mentioning
right um so so here i think you were
suggesting using a little bit of data
from the target domain um we go all the
way and we ask what's the the ratio of
your error if you were to use the uh the
metadata from other domains compared to
if you were to have access to uh
to uh to the target sample
uh but that's that's spiritually very
related the first part of the question
i'm not sure i completely understood i i
think you were pointing out that the
rules that we use
are uh directly applied to the training
data not necessarily taking into account
the data generating process
uh so if that's what you were saying
then i agree that that is correct
um so right just like when you train a
black box algorithm you're not
adapting that algorithm necessarily to a
an underlying structural model of how
the data was generated
but if i misunderstood the question
please let me know
yeah thanks for the answers um
yeah i think that that makes sense
to me
um i guess the the other worry was that
there potentially could be a better
model
that's not kind of
discoverable or
uh does not score well under this
measure if that makes sense
oh well that's interesting okay so
that's certainly possible but then we
have to decide what we mean by better
right
uh
yeah
uh but but yeah let me just also uh say
again that
in contrast with the domain
generalization uh literature here we're
not going to be so focused on finding
the best approach for out of domain
prediction um we're going to be
interested instead of this question of
given a specific approach how can we
evaluate it
was there another question in the back i
can't quite a couple more
okay hi
um
let's see how to ask my question i mean
there's a sense to me in which this
looks kind of like a standard
statistical learning problem but somehow
you've like i don't know embedded this
kind of hierarchical structure or
something in but like just looking at
the slide we're looking at right now we
have all of our samples from
you know s1 to sn drawn from a
distribution i think you said sn plus
one is drawn from the same
target distribution i think
so it's
i don't know so i'm just a little
confused it seems to me like
you could like maybe
the right idiosyncratic black box model
that's sort of designed for this setup
which maybe we haven't designed yet
because we haven't worked hard on this
particular setup would
possibly do just as well and then i
don't know then we have to lift to the
next hierarchy or something i don't know
it do you see what i mean like it just
yeah absolutely you know so that's a
great point so uh the setting is in a
sense isomorphic to this the usual uh
statistical learning framework so
certainly it's easy to see that this
nests the usual out of sample test if
you fix the uh the probability
distributions to be same the same across
all the samples and take the sample size
to be one
you can actually also show that uh under
the appropriate redefinition so
essentially thinking about the samples
as observations you can also nest this
in the other direction um so you know
that's why i uh
i think this is really a very
straightforward generalization of the
usual framework but this new uh these
new definitions are going to allow us to
speak more clearly about the transfer
prediction problem
okay which is going to be especially
useful once we go to the application
uh yeah my question is is i think fairly
basic and so apologies about that um i
just want to understand does this
i believe my understanding is that the
relationship between x and y can change
between like your different samples
exactly yeah and so
if if it can change in an unbounded way
like right like if my sample sn plus one
can be like completely arbitrarily like
the relationship between x and y can be
completely arbitrarily different
then you can say nothing right and so
what you're doing is you're using the
fact that these are all from some
distribution so you have kind of a
distribution okay is is that is that
basically that's not basic at all that's
a fantastic summary what's going on
right so the first important point is
the sense in which this is uh
okay at least superficially different
from the usual out of sample test is
that the samples are drawn from
different distributions
all right um and they could be very
different distributions right as you're
pointing out the assumption that we're
making and which is going to we're going
to leverage
substantially is that these
distributions are themselves iid from
another distribution
okay and that's going to allow us to say
some things okay so that's a perfect
subway then into our results
okay so let me tell you what we can say
um okay so let me first give you a
simpler version of our results which is
going to illustrate uh some of the
underlying intuition
um so let's start by fixing some subset
t of observed samples to use for
training
i think drew has his hand raised
uh thanks i i just that the the last
question
sort of echoed something from the
previous question so i just want to
encourage you to slow down 30 seconds
and make sure people track this it's
super important that it's not the same
distribution each sample
rather the samples are exchangeable and
as annie said this is a higher level
distribution picking distributions but
maybe you should put that slide back up
and talk a little slower and
go over it once more because it's
absolutely key
um sure i think we can use this slide
right so i think uh okay but hopefully
people did understand so the so let me
just merge the two last questions though
maybe that will be useful
um so the sense in which this is
different from the usual out of sample
test is that we have samples drawn from
different distributions the question
before that i understood as pointing out
that since we've made this assumption
that the distributions are themselves
independently drawn from yet another
distribution
there's a sense in which our setting can
be seen as very analogous to the usual
out of sample test if you think about
these individual samples as themselves
observations
right we're just imposing the
independence at a higher level
okay great so suppose we fixed some set
uh subset of samples that we're using
for training
okay for example s1 and s2
that's our training data
now here we're going to start seeing the
value of using just some subset of the
metadata as opposed to all of the
metadata for training
which is that we now have a bunch of
observed samples
which we can take as test domains
all right so then for each of the test
domains uh which are in fact observed
samples in our metadata
as well as for the new target sample
which we don't get to see
we're going to have a transfer error
which is the transfer error you get when
you train on the initial
chosen set of training domains
but then test
for the subsequent um
so here for example this etf3 is a
transfer error from s1 and s2
to s3
right so on to etn and then finally we
have the transfer error from the
training samples to the target sample
so this gives us n plus one minus the
cardinality of t transfer errors in
total
and then here this uh this independence
assumption the id assumption comes in
crucially right so although the
distributions governing these samples
can be very different
um
because the samples are iid we know that
the ranks of these transfer errors must
be uniformly distributed up to ties
so what i can do is i can order
the ranks of the observed transfer
errors so this is the smallest to the
biggest
and then the rank of the
transfer error on the target sample
which remember is what we're interested
in and don't know
that rank is equally likely to be at any
of these positions indicated by the
arrows
so therefore we can bound the
probability that the transfer error on
the target sample
is of rank greater than any r
to be the following
is that a hand on the back
yeah sorry yeah go for it is is this
this seems very related to conformal
inference to me
absolutely it's exactly yeah this is
those are the techniques we're using
here yeah okay all right cool thank you
okay fantastic um so so we can use that
uh to provide a one-sided bound and we
can use essentially the same argument
for a two-sided bound right
uh so fixing any rl in rh
the probability that the transfer error
on the target sample
is of rank strictly smaller than rl or
strictly larger than rh can likewise be
bounded
right so this is essentially a warm up
for our main result uh we can use this
argument to show that uh
that the uh that we can produce a
confidence interval for the target
the transfer error in the target sample
um by looking at the
our elf
largest and our youth largest uh so this
is for our lower or upper
um observed
transfer errors in our metadata okay let
me do that a bit more slowly so for any
r let's define this to be the earth's
largest observed transfer error when
transferring to test domains in our
metadata
right then the probability that the
transfer error onto the target sample
falls outside of this interval here
okay is no more than this right hand
side
therefore we can take this interval as a
two-sided confidence interval uh for
this
transfer error on the target sample
which we don't know with the following
confidence guarantee
okay great so hopefully that gives some
underlying intuition for how this id
assumption is going to be very useful
however this previous approach uh makes
a sort of weird choice which is that we
single out a set of training domains t
um to use for training a priority right
for example i chose american bulacaria
in the example that we were looking at
but exante all of these samples in the
metadata are symmetric so there's really
no reason to use the american and
bulgarian data for training compared to
say the american and chinese data sets
so a very natural approach then
is to randomize the choice of samples
that we use for training
okay that's exactly what we're going to
do we're going to pick a fixed size
and we're going to randomize over all
possible
sets of training domains of that fixed
size
right and our main result provides
confidence intervals
for the
training error on the target sample when
the set of training domains is itself
random and the approach is going to be
as follows what we're going to do is
we're going to pull together
all the transfer errors
when we vary both the set of training
domains as well as the test domain and
we're going to show that we can use
quantiles of that pooled sample as the
lower and upward bound for this
confidence interval
all right so let me do that in more
detail now
so previously we talked through how to
provide a confidence interval
when we fixed the set of training
domains to be for example uh s1 and s2
okay as i was pointing out there's no
reason to pick one two we could pick two
three
um so now what we're going to do is
we're going to pull together
all transfer errors
from a set of training domains t
to a new test set
which is outside of that training set
but we're going to do this for all
subsets t of some fixed size n of t
okay so for example if we were to fix t
to be one two then the transfer errors
in that case and here we're only going
to collect the observed transfer errors
so we're looking at the transfer error
to sample three all the way to the
transfer error up to sample n
okay we're not including the target
domain
um now if i change the set of training
domains to be two and three now we have
the transfer error to sample s1
okay so on and so forth to sample sn
we're going to do this for all subsets
of size and t
that's going to give us
a pooled sample of transfer errors
and then for any tau
for any quantile tau we're going to
define e of tau to be the
quantile of that pooled sample
right and
our main result says that we can use
that to provide uh to construct
confidence intervals for this quantity
here
okay so what is this
this is the transfer error onto the
target sample
when the set of trading domains is not
fixed but is instead a random variable
whose distribution is uniform
over all subsets of 1 through n of some
fixed size nft
and the main result says that if we pick
any quantile
tau we construct the confidence interval
where the left um where the lower bound
is the one minus health quantile
of the pooled sample of transfer errors
that we just constructed on the last
slide
the upper bound is the health quantile
okay then the probability that this
transfer error onto the target sample is
outside of this interval can be bounded
as follows therefore this interval can
be used to provide a
is a two-sided confidence interval for
the transfer error on the target sample
with this guarantee
the main technical challenge here is
that although we can use the previous
argument
to construct a confidence interval for
each draw of t
these intervals are going to be
statistically dependent across these
different draws and that dependence is
something that we have to account for
in constructing these confidence
intervals
so just one more comment on this so note
that these confidence intervals that
we're creating describe variation in the
transfer error due to two sources
so first there's the usual source which
is uncertainty because your data set is
finite
there's a second source which is a
variation in the transfer error due to
the random selection of the training and
test domains
because of that second source of
variation we actually don't expect the
length of these intervals to shrink to
zero as we acquire more domains okay
that might seem a little bit funny
especially if we're talking about
confidence intervals so therefore
actually for the rest of the talk i'm
not going to call these confidence
intervals anymore i'm going to call them
forecast intervals to make that
distinction clear
all right so any questions about these
results uh
otherwise i'll
subsequently go into the application
yes we have a question
sorry there's something i really don't
understand the
when it's a forecast interval
um in a way when we apply this target
interval it does tend to be something
that happens in the future whereas the
other domains we collected that we are
able to train on came from you know at
least 10 steps in the past
in that way how would you
justify the id
domain
that's actually an example that we give
for uh in the paper for why the id
assumption is restrictive right so if
you have in mind a time series then you
you know very well may expect a
correlation um uh across these uh you
know across different these different
periods which in which cases id
assumption doesn't quite make sense um i
do want to say that i didn't mean to
imply so i might have used the word
future in the talk but there's no sense
in which this target sample has to be
acquired at a later point in time what's
crucial is just that it's unseen
all right uh and so you know there's
there's many different uh ways in which
we might think of the domain so
different time steps is certainly one
kind of domain variation but
as i'm showing this example another
potential domain variation it's just
subject rules right so how american
subjects think about uh choices between
risky lotteries
versus bulgarian subjects
great any other questions
was that a no i couldn't quite hear that
it's a no there was a person walking by
outside on the cell phone got it okay
all right great so then uh let's spend
the rest of the time on the application
all right so we look at a classic
problem from economics which is
prediction of certainty equivalence okay
so the setup is as follows
a subject is going to be offered a risky
lottery
so there's two possible prizes with
corresponding probabilities
and we're going to ask what is the
dollar amount x
such as the subject is indifferent
between receiving the outcome the random
outcome of the lottery
versus receiving x dollars for sure
that dollar about x we call the
subject's certainty equivalent for the
lottery
but this is a prediction problem i can
ask you if i just give you the lottery
can you predict the subject's certainty
equivalent
so what we've done is we've constructed
a metadata set consisting of samples of
reported certainty equivalents from 44
subject pools
so here we're going to be interpreting
domains and subject pools i'm actually i
want to put a star on that that's
something we're going to come back to uh
later
okay these samples come from 14 papers
from experimental economics
so actually the samples the
uh the different domains that we're
going to use they differ actually not
just in the subject pools but also in
other things like the framing of the
lotteries
so we're going to expect that models of
risk preferences that are trained on
some of these samples will still be
predictive of data in the other samples
but it's going to be imperfectly
predictive and we want to quantify how
good that prediction is
so we're going to consider decision
rules based on an economic model as well
as two block boxes
okay the economic model is uh something
called cumulative prospect theory the
two black boxes that we consider are the
random forest and a two-layer neural net
um so this part is probably more
familiar for the audience so let me just
go through this in more detail so
cumulative prospect theory is a
well-known model in economics for risk
preferences
and uh the idea is as follows so
essentially it's an embellished expected
value okay but we're going to change two
things so first we're not necessarily
going to suppose that uh your evaluation
of money is linear okay we're going to
allow for curvature and we're going to
also suppose that you tweet gains or you
interpret gains differently from how you
interpret losses okay so this
function here is the value function over
money um it's described by this
parametric form there's two free
parameters alpha and beta okay so
whatever is a z here is a dollar amount
v of z is your evaluation of that dollar
amount okay additionally we're going to
suppose that subjects uh don't in fact
correctly perceive probabilities so this
part is really uh
really both parts are inspired by large
quantities of experimental evidence
so the idea here is whatever the
probability is there's actually some
distortion going on in the subject's
mind where you actually overweight small
probabilities and you underweight large
probabilities
so here this w of p is the probability
waiting function so given true
probability p you perceive it as w of p
and that takes a very specific uh
parametric form given here again that
has a two free parameters delta and
gamma so then given a specific lottery
right where these are the two prize
amounts p is the probability of the uh
larger amount
this here this is what i call the
embellished expected value that's going
to be the utility of the lottery and
then this here is going to be the dollar
amount that you consider equivalent
in terms of utility to the lottery
itself
so fixing any values for these four
parameters we're going to get a strategy
and this model we're going to identify
with a set of strategies where we vary
the values of the parameter and here
we're using range restrictions for the
parameters that come from the literature
so the decision rule corresponding to
this model um is going to say
you give me the training data
i'm going to find the strategy in this
set sigma star that best fits the
training data so minimizes error on the
training data
that's going to be a strategy
um we can use that strategy for
prediction on the new target sample
right so that's our economic model and
then in addition we have the two black
boxes so sure this audience is very
familiar so let me not spend too much
detail on it but we uh we trade a random
forest which is an ensemble of decision
trees and we train a neural let and that
which implies these non-linear
transformations to the input features so
for sds the input features are simply uh
the description of the lottery itself so
the two prizes as well as the the
probabilities
all right so as a warm up before we get
to the transfer exercise let's first
just consider the usual out of sample
prediction problem
so what we're going to do is domain by
domain
we're going to take the sample in that
domain
okay and we're going to split it into
training and test parts okay so in fact
we just we use the usual ten-fold
cross-validation so we're splitting into
ten subsets using nine for training uh
testing on the final choice
okay then averaging over the errors of
the the ten possible choices of test set
and here so the crucial contrast right
between this and the transfer prediction
problem that's that's really our focus
is that here the training data and the
test data are drawn from the same
distribution
what that means is that given enough
data
we're going to expect that the black
boxes
can actually learn detailed structure in
that domain
and outperform the economic model
right that is essentially what we find
so in 39 of the 44 domains we find that
the random forest error out of sample
error is smaller than the out-of-sample
error of the economic model okay the
improvement doesn't turn out to be large
um so here this is the cdf of out of
sample errors for the random forest
algorithm that's the orange as well as
for the cpt model that's the blue
okay and here we have a distribution
because we have 44 domains so we're
looking at the the errors
across those different domains
you can see the curves are pretty
similar uh the the orange curve is
slightly better
we also actually looked at the in sample
errors so that's going to further
advantage the black box because we're
not even testing out a sample so the
more flexible approach is simply going
to be better uh there are the actually
the cdf comparison again looks pretty
similar uh so the the block box
continues to be better naturally uh and
actually the difference uh the more
surprising things that the difference is
is not actually that large
okay so from these results alone
we can't distinguish uh whether cpt and
the random forest are achieving similar
out-of-sample errors
by learning effectively the same
representation given the training data
or by learning different representations
that just turn out to have similar
errors
right so that's a puzzle
and then if the answer is the second
right if they actually are learning
different representations
is it the case that the random forest is
achieving better out of sample errors
by learning generalizable structure that
the economic model is missing
or by learning idiosyncratic details
behavior in each domain which in fact
are not going to transfer across the
domains
so we can tease apart these two
explanations by um evaluating the
transfer performance now of these models
using our main results
all right so just to remind you this was
our main result
um
we said that if we looked at the one
minus health and health quantile of
transfer errors of observed transfer
errors
that would give us a confidence interval
uh here
n recall is just the total number of
samples in the metadata
that's just fixed right for us that's
44.
the other two parameters are going to be
choices that we make so nf tau is the
number of samples in our metadata that
we're using for training
and then tau
is the percentile of the pool transfer
errors that we're going to be using to
construct these intervals in principle
we can choose any choice of tau
that's just going to give us confidence
intervals of different levels of
different widths
okay the wider confidence intervals are
going to correspond to lower confidence
uh sorry higher confidence guarantees
and here we're going to set nft to be
equal to one and we're going to set town
to be 0.95
all right so we're looking at the the
fifth percentile and the 95th percentile
and that's going to allow us to answer
the following question so if i draw one
domain for my metadata at random i use
that one domain for training
i uh apply my decision rule get a
strategy use that strategy to bring in a
new domain
what is the 71 percentile uh 71
forecast interval for how well i'm going
to do on this new domain and 71 here is
applying our results here to figure out
what the confidence guarantee is
all right and here's what we find
so these are the three forecast
intervals
okay the main takeaway is that the upper
bounds for the two block box methods uh
are substantially larger than the the
upper bound for the uh the economic
model so the random forest upper bound
is about twice as large the neural that
upper bound is even larger
and note that this is despite the fact
that we saw that within domain the out
of sample errors were actually quite
similar
all right so that's that's intriguing
because it's telling us that although
these representations that the economic
model
and the black box algorithms were
learning had similar errors out of
sample within domain
the representation that cpt is learning
does indeed have different implications
in these transfer prediction tasks
compared to the representations that
were learned by the random forest and
the neural net and moreover the
representation learned by
seems to be generalizing substantially
better right so for this new domain we
can be pretty uh pretty certain that the
transfer error is going to be
in this range for the black boxes
there's a possibility it's much larger
right you might also notice that here
the the forecast intervals are
overlapping that's actually less
informative uh than uh
it seems initially so the reason is this
uh this observation that we made
previously right so these intervals are
reflecting in part variation and error
due to the random selection of training
and target domains
so we're going to expect an overlap in
these forecast intervals
whenever the cpt error on the upper tail
trading and target domains
or in a sense the worst case choice of
training and target domains
exceeds the black box errors on the
lower tail or best case choices of
training and test domains
so whenever this is the case which is
kind of a weak uh property then we would
expect the distributions of training
errors to be overlapping and then
correspondingly it's not surprising for
these forecast intervals to also be
overlapping
all right so there uh remember we chose
a very specific choice of tau to use to
construct the confidence interval uh we
could have chosen different choices so i
think this figure is actually quite uh
quite useful so what we're showing you
here is the x-axis is the percentile
okay it's essentially talbot percentiles
instead of quantiles
uh the y-axis is the transfer error
so what this tells us is fix any of the
given methods
fix your favorite percentile
what is that percentile of transfer
error
in the pooled sample of transfer errors
and essentially we use this figure to
produce the original confidence
intervals
okay also if it helps this is an inverse
cdf
so previously what we did is we picked
uh arbitrarily tau to be equal to 0.95
so then one minus tau in tau
right we looked at what that uh
percentile of transfer error was okay
for example let's take the neural net
right so what is uh the 5th and 95th
percentile of transfer errors using the
neural net
those two numbers gave us the two bounds
for our confidence intervals so this is
just showing you uh for the forecast
interval so this is just showing you the
forecast interval vertically uh but
that's exactly what i showed you here a
moment ago
and then of course we don't have to
choose 5 and 95. you know if you want
you can choose tao to be equal to 0.75
so then we've got uh 25 and 75 as the
two percentiles again we have the
corresponding numbers again we can
produce a corresponding forecast
interval just the confidence guarantee
here is going to be lower corresponding
to the more narrow forecast interval but
you can see that whatever tile you
choose
right because the the two curves for the
black box algorithms
are everywhere above the curve for cpt
it doesn't really matter what how you
choose we're always going to get these
uh forecast intervals for the black box
algorithms
that qualitatively have the same
comparison with the economic model so
we're going to get wider confidence
intervals with much larger upper bounds
when we consider the black box methods
compared to the economic model
all right and also from the speaker what
you would see is that
although although these curves are
everywhere above for the black box
algorithms compared to the economic
model
in this region actually they look very
similar
right so up to about the 55th percentile
of transfer um
yeah of the transfer errors
uh
the methods actually aren't really that
distinguished from one another
so what it tells us is it's not that uh
the economic model sometimes does much
better at transfer prediction than the
black box methods ever do
right the best case transfer errors are
actually pretty similar
the distinction is really that the black
boxes sometimes do much worse
right they sometimes achieve transfer
errors
that the uh that you're just never going
to get if you use the economic model for
transfer prediction
all right so that concludes uh the main
part of the results uh but i want to
talk about this choice now of how we
define the domains
so how the forecast intervals should be
interpreted very much depends on how the
domains are defined right so for the
main analysis so far we've defined it as
subject pools so are we looking at
american subjects or
bulgarian subjects
now we don't view it as possible or even
desirable to provide a measure of
transferability that's not going to be
sensitive to that definition
and in fact we can apply results to
different definitions of domains to
understand across what dimensions
a model is going to transfer better or
worse
and we can in fact
look at that within our specific
application
so what we do next is we redefine
domains
instead of subject pools we're going to
define domains as papers
right the papers from which we got the
data sets
in this case our metadata is now going
to consist of 14 samples instead of the
original 44
where each sample comes from one of the
14 papers that we used
and we can conduct exactly the same
analysis
all right and this is what we find
so this is on the left hand side is the
figure we were looking at a moment ago
on the right hand side is the the same
figure that we get if we now have the uh
the domains defined as papers instead of
subject rules
and the main difference uh you can see
here is that this region that we were
discussing a moment ago
where the three methods look very
similar
okay now we actually do get separation
right so from the very beginning
it's clear that the black box transfer
errors at every percentile are clearly
higher than the uh
the corresponding percentiles
for the econ models uh transfer errors
right so it seems like cpt's
generalization ability is actually
becoming more pronounced
when we're transferring across papers
rather than transferring across subject
pools
all right so that's a puzzle why is that
the case and so
to the best of our understanding this is
what's going on
so one of the 14 papers that we're using
is actually a meta study
that paper itself
consists of third 30 samples
of certainty equivalents from 30
different countries
now in the first analysis we treated
those 30 samples as distinct samples
so that means that we considered
transfer prediction tasks
training on one of those 30 samples and
predicting another
now transfer errors between samples of
this paper
constituted 870 of the total uh 1892
transfer errors that we've looked at
so that's actually a sizable component
in the second analysis we've defined
domains as papers we've merged these 30
samples now as a single sample so we're
no longer considering transfer
prediction between those uh or across
those samples from this paper
all right so now we can ask you what's
going on what's special about the
transfer prediction tasks between
samples in this paper
and we can understand that by again
repeating our main analysis
now limiting to these three samples
as again a new definition of domains
all right and here's what we find
so now these three curves for cpt the
economic model and the two black boxes
are virtually indistinguishable from one
another so this is telling us that cpt's
transfer performance across samples in
this specific paper uh doesn't actually
seem to be better than the black boxes
ability to generalize
all right so so what's going on why is
that the case
it turns out that the 30 samples in this
paper
involve certainty equivalents that are
reported for the same lotteries
so what the authors did is they went to
different countries right 30 different
countries they're asking different
people but they were asking different
people the same questions which is what
are your reported certainty equivalents
for this list of lotteries
okay that list didn't vary across
samples in this paper
it did vary across different papers
now it turns out that the variation in
the average syringe equivalent across
different countries for each of these
lotteries is not large i can actually
let's see how we're doing on time it can
actually show you
so the x axis is the different lotteries
and the different dots for each of these
lotteries are different average
certainty equivalents for the 30 uh
countries
in this in this paper and what you can
see is of course there is some variation
but that variation actually doesn't turn
out to be that large
so what the black box algorithm can do
is essentially learn up a table uh learn
a table lookup procedure
where you just memorize for each of
these lotteries what the average
certainty equivalent is uh for those
lotteries
now it's not going to be a perfect
prediction right so if you start with
the vietnam data you learn the average
certainty equivalent for these say like
28 lotteries using the vietnam data set
that's not going to be a perfect
prediction for the u.s data set
uh but because this variation is not
large it's it's not really a bad uh
bad uh algorithm for prediction
all right
note that there are the black box can
therefore achieve reasonably low
transfer errors
across these different sample sets uh
without actually learning how to
extrapolate to new lotteries
right you can extrapolate to prediction
of other countries answers for the theme
lotteries
we're not testing you on how you're
going to do
um
is asked to predict certainty
equivalence for new lotteries outside of
this data set
so this provides a reasonable uh an
interesting conjecture let me quickly
take a look at the chat okay five four
minutes okay so we might conjecture then
that black box methods are uh going to
perform worse
when the domains are different in terms
of the underlying problem instances that
were that we're looking at and when the
domains
require um when this transfer prediction
problem requires further extrapolation
that's exactly when the black box
methods are going to do worse relative
to the uh economic models so this is a
conjecture um we've posed uh it's not
something that we've pursued in great
detail uh it's also an interesting
question of just even how you would
define further extrapolation
okay i want to leave a bit of time
for questions
i guess we've got three minutes so let
me just quickly tell you uh these other
two things that are in the paper that i
skipped in the talk
uh so first uh so so what i've shown you
is confidence intervals for the random
transfer error
in the paper we also provide finite
sample confidence intervals for
quantiles of the transfer error so for
example you might be interested in uh
providing an interval for the median
transfer error
so we have that the the results are
qualitatively similar to what we looked
at in the talk uh and we also provide
finite sample cost confidence intervals
for the expected value of the transfer
errors all right so just to be clear
we've got the random transfer error of
the quantile and now the expectation
and here our confidence intervals uh use
bounds on what we call transfer rather
macro complexity so it's actually
leveraging this analogy between the the
usual statistical learning framework and
uh our transfer learning framework uh we
can adapt existing results uh for our
setting
um so here we provide an uh an analogous
definition of radical complexity for
this transfer prediction problem
using that we can develop these bounds
uh turns out that the bounds that we get
aren't very informative in our
application they're just huge uh
actually so for this audience you know
if you know about um empirical
applications of radio macro complexity
uh in computer science where those
bounds have been useful i i'd be very
curious to hear
because our understanding so far is that
they're they're useful for
classification problems but but not
necessarily useful for other loss
functions
was that a comment
okay so anyway so we do provide these
bounds in the paper uh for for use in
other applications but this is the
reason we don't emphasize it in our
paper
okay so just to conclude uh our results
quantify how well a model's performance
on one domain is going to extrapolate to
other domains
in an application we've shown that the
predictions of cpt and economic model
um
oh this is actually reversed
oh no sorry this is correct okay
outperform
those of black box
models on out of domain tests
despite the fact that the black box
methods actually have lower
out-of-sample prediction errors within a
given domain
so these results provide support for the
intuition that economic models learn
regularities that are general
across a variety of domains
um while these more flexible black box
methods are sometimes learning
irregularities that are idiosyncratic to
a given domain in a sense thus
overfitting to uh to the domain
okay great thank you uh thank you for
the questions and happy to take more so
i see one again in the back
thank you for the nice talk uh just when
you thought there was a comment a minute
ago some people in the audience were
laughing when you asked for useful
applications of rather mocker complexity
right hopefully because
are they laughing because there aren't
anywhere because perhaps
so
um
i guess i'll ask my question because you
said it's your first time giving the
talk and you welcome feedback
um i'm look i'm not a machine learning
person but i'm just kind of thinking of
this from like the point of view of
someone who does maybe deep learning or
neural nets like my understanding is
that they're so super flexible that they
can do anything
so if they're not doing as well as your
other model here your economic model
then i think somebody would just say
that you and you didn't tell us much
about your neural network architecture
and all this so they i think they would
just say well you didn't you know
optimize your hyper parameters correctly
right like you just didn't explore the
space of possible neural networks
sufficiently and that's why your
economic model is outperforming and
moreover your economic model seems to
have some domain information
such as losses loom larger than gains
which i guess you could feed to your
neural network as well so it seems to me
that with the right neural network
design you should get exactly the same
thing as what your economic model is
telling us
okay that's that's a very interesting
and uh somewhat provocative comment so
so okay let me let me see two things in
response to that um so the first is
we're not trying to conclude black boxes
are worse than economic models okay we
certainly don't have that that's way
more sweeping right we have that in a
specific application uh it looks like
cpt a specific economic model does
better than two specific black box
algorithms at this transfer prediction
task right so we see the contribution of
this paper you know not as saying that
uh
not as providing a definitive ranking of
these different methods but rather as
providing a method that you can apply
for any algorithm you have in mind right
so suppose you go ahead and you do tweak
the neural net that we've been using
writing you improve it uh great now we
can come back and apply these results
again produce the same confidence
intervals look at whether it is in fact
true that that tweaked version of the
neural net actually improves upon uh cpt
and the random forest
so we want to provide this method that
can be used many of these cases to
compare these methods by the transfer
performance and i actually think it'd be
super interesting uh if somebody did
actually start looking at ways of
merging insights that we've built into
cbt um we took those insights and built
them into these different deep learning
techniques and try to actually uh to see
whether there's actually a method that's
going to achieve not just this better
out of sample performance within domain
but even better transfer prediction
performance that would be very cool i
think
but you know it actually is possible
billy that there is something about uh
these low dimensional economic models
that do just provide general a better uh
general not generalizability it agrees
an empirical question we would have to
find out
was there a question also in the back
yeah sorry um
so i think
one question i would have sorry
did i jump in first i'd buy my hand up
um
just
yes it's of course right that machine
learning algorithms
uh do better if you tune their features
but i i understand this point
conceptually and make an equally
provocative uh response i mean in
principle couldn't we just add the
certainty equivalents predicted by cpt
as features into a neural net and let it
use that and they would previously
always do at least as well is that i
mean no no that's a great point right so
that further goes to this right the
distinction between economic models and
these black boxes is not that clear
right so as the uh the question was was
indicating
um you know it's it's not really that
we're trying to
to say right
you know all neural nets uh
are going to be worse
certainly these black box algorithms
that are taking as input the economic
models predictions is likely going to be
doing better and that's a very
interesting direction for future work
uh okay
so
very briefly i will just say in
biophysics we often use like neural nets
or linear models to predict the
parameters on an individual level that
we then feed into biophysical models you
could obviously do that here right so
you could individually predict using a
linear model or a neural net the
parameters that you feed into cpt
instead of like fitting those on whole
populations you'd fit them on
individuals and you'd use this kind of
some linear or neural net
parameterization there but that's just
you know a comment in conversation with
what has been talked about yeah and it's
almost like an inverse of what drew was
saying so instead of putting the econ
model into the black box you want to
somehow fit the black box into the okay
yeah
yeah and that's very common in
biophysics uh now um but anyway the more
generally i'd be interested in whether
these
uh
generalization issues slash gains are
driven by shifts in the relationship
between x and y or shifts in x right so
in in computer science we've kind of
done a lot of work on kind of john
ducey's stuff and his group stuff on
distributionally robust optimization and
more recently kind of omar reingold and
his kind of community stuff on uh kind
of multi-calibration and those things
are designed for when there isn't kind
of confounding right so like the the
relationship between x and y is not
changing the change in the distribution
and y is driven by changes in the
distribution of x between domains right
and so i would be interested to see how
kind of neural nets or random forests
trained with dro
would work here like are you
is the issue that there is unobserved
confounding that is drawn kind of in
this iid way from some like global
distribution between samples or is it
driven by differences between
populations in the different samples
like differences in x that are inducing
distributions in y yeah fantastic um so
first i actually i can't because the
screen's very small so i can't actually
see who's asking the question but i
would love to follow up and get those
references that you're you're mentioning
um but i think what you're saying is
exactly uh in line with what we're
finding here right so
the 30 samples in this paper
exactly have the feature that the x
space was the same
right so there was a little bit of
variation in the conditional just
distribution of y given x but because
all the domains have the same x's it's
not uh this transfer prediction problem
is in a sense less demanding right on
the other hand when we're transferring
across papers
now actually the x space is different
across uh so for us that means the set
of lotteries okay but that's going to be
different across the different samples
and that's exactly when the black box
method does worse so this this upper
tail
uh is consisting of transferring across
these very different sets of lotteries
um so our understanding is that that's
really what's tripping up the the black
boxes compared to the economic models
yeah
thank you
another question
[Music]
yeah i had um just one question
regarding when you did the transfer rod
marker complexity
did it give you anything in terms of
like
scalings and parameters that were
informative like did it have a
i don't know a form that was helpful i
would kind of argue that the value of
rademacher complexity isn't to be a good
bound per se but is to give us some nice
like worst case scaling or worst case
intuition of like
this is how a number of parameters
should scale like classically in linear
models right we would say well okay i
need like
i need my measure a number of
measurements to go like
d over epsilon squared to get an epsilon
bound and
of course the constant in front of
rademacher would be hopelessly
pessimistic
for it to be useful but still like
d over epsilon squared would be a useful
number
got it so we didn't really see any
insights like that we could we could
yeah go back to that and um
and check uh or to think harder about
that but i think part of what your your
and your question is getting at is um
there's like a difference between
qualitative insights that we get from
these asymptotic results versus like the
practical usage of these uh these
intervals for uh these bounds for finite
samples and
i i think especially when we're thinking
about something like transfer prediction
then having finite simple bounds really
becomes extra important um and also
bounds that are valid for small n
because you know
we felt actually extremely grateful that
we were able to construct a metadata set
with 44 domains in general it's just you
know having a large number of domains is
not going to be feasible for many many
problems we're interested in
another question here
hi uh thank you so much for your talk um
i was wondering i had a question on the
analysis at the end when you're choosing
kind of different choices for the
domains
i was wondering whether the like choice
of which domains you have affects how
well the iad assumption is satisfied and
whether that would affect the analysis
and conclusions at all as well yeah no
that's a great question i think of it
almost as um
the choice that remains is your iad
assumption
so whatever you think is iad
that that shouldn't be your your
definition of domains
right so maybe you think that data sets
across papers are drawn independently or
maybe you think that data sets over
sample pools i think that in practice
it's you know not that easy to think
through what the correct independence
assumption is uh but you're exactly
right there's this equivalence between
how we're defining domains and what the
iid assumption means in our framework
sorry one one last question um so pretty
common
since whatever 2019 in conformal stuff
is to do conformal quantile regression
um i'm wondering if you guys have
thought about that and how that might
give you
you know obviously you can't get
conditional validity with conformal but
you can get more individual level
confidence intervals if you do that kind
of thing i'm wondering if you if you
don't think that would work because the
samples are too small
i think actually maybe you're referring
to this so we do provide confidence
intervals for the quantiles of these
distributions and and those intervals
will in fact shrink as the number of
domains uh gets larger
um so i just don't know how to skip it
um
a time but
uh the results we get here are really
quite similar
so we still get these wider and higher
upper bound confidence intervals for the
different quantiles of this distribution
well thanks for all the questions and
let's thank annie again
thank you
so we have a 20-minute break now and
we'll be back at 11 o'clock for the next
talk of the session